I've been putting hydrogen peroxide on the open tumor on my throat. One dropper full
seven several times a day. You said hydrogen peroxide can be taken, can be toxic, take it
internally. Yes, it can. Is this okay to do and how much is too much? Well, it depends on
what type of hydrogen peroxide you're using. You should, if you're taking something internally,
like that you bid or only be using the 3% hydrogen peroxide, not the 35% hydrogen peroxide.
Even at that, I would attempt, I would attempt to not swallow so much of it.
That can be a strong take it internally. So if you're doing a dropper full several times a day,
you're probably just fine. I wouldn't be concerned about it. Just make sure it's just the
3% hydrogen peroxide, not the 35%. Even the 3% hydrogen peroxide, I don't think it's made for
internal use. I would be careful. I would maybe substitute hydrogen peroxide and think about
substituting colloidal silver instead of the hydrogen peroxide. So colloidal
silver has other benefits that may, that you could just swallow that, that could be even better for you
or have other benefits for you.